what up everybody i'm here with tim get
is now 10 before we introduce our guest
yeah who absolutely needs a zero
introduction I want you to know
something yeah growing up I was an
overweight child yes and watching this
man do what he does for a living often
made me wonder why why do people do that
what makes a man want to fly through the
air on escape ladies and gentlemen mr
tony hawk thank you how are you sir good
thanks thanks so much for coming lame
has a ton of questions for you about
your right okay this is a bit surreal
for me Tony Hawk's Pro Skater probably
one of the most defining things of my
life let alone video games just things
from the soundtrack to the gameplay to
the experiences I had with my friends oh
my god it means so much to me watching
you in the X Games but all throughout my
childhood and all everything it's crazy
to have you here right now how excited
are you for Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 50
I'm out of my mind excited I mean you
know the idea that we get to bring we
get to relaunch the series and go back
to our roots of what made it pop it in
the first place kind of picked up where
we left off on the THPS side and into
the new technology with the online
elements I mean it's it's unbelievable I
mean I haven't been doing III in a few
years so yeah the most good yeah I feel
like Redemption here is it as loud as
you remember it being it's actually not
as loud as I remember it okay I remember
yeah I mean I remember it being like
just volume Morris at every booth yeah
still a couple days manageable I think
it'll be playing nice today yeah yeah
it'll get worse day yeah so THPS coming
back what does that mean like why is
this not just a Tony Hawk something else
project a project you know what I mean a
different title why is it THPS are we
getting classic mode back are we getting
the two-minute runs though it seemed
familiar with that's that's exactly why
we have it it's called THPS it's back to
that type of game play the same controls
same kind of challenges and but but the
idea that we brought it to all the new
architecture of the new consoles and an
online element that we never had before
you you can create a level have up to 20
people playing in a once from all over
the world I mean that's what that kind
of stuff is that was impossible when we
left off the series there and
now we're embracing all that that's
great man so from the classic tony hawk
games 1 through 4 what are your
favorites uh if i had to choose one
through four i would be 22 i think
because that put us on the map of being
a genre a video game it was the game
changer the manual man it did it yeah I
mean and also just the idea that that
that's the one you're the first one we
were we were still figuring it out yeah
it was it was solid but but the second
one just brought us into a realm of
recognition and I think it puts
skateboarding on the map in a lot of
ways and I'm hugely proud of it yeah I
mean that definitely is true I think
that it's such an influential game to my
generation of people where I wasn't so
much aware of skateboarding as a culture
and has a thing until this game came and
I was like I need to skateboard and all
my friends were the same way like we
need to do this and learn how to do it I
never got good but it was still fun
doing it you know I remember the tech
decks and all that stuff yeah it was it
was a whole thing and Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater being that kind of annual event
of a new one coming out i remember being
such a huge deal and playing through
those classic levels what are your
favorite levels favorite levels Wow oh
yes that's Jenny questions uh I'm bad at
associating which levels are in which
game yeah but off the top of my head
downhill jam was always fun for me
because it had it had a big vert ramp so
I'd like to keep a real up on the ground
yeah and it was also the first start to
finish level where we ever had but but
in later games I love Tokyo all we have
Rio oh yeah we can't go right out the
plaza they break the little offense and
get that seeking yeah yeah and school
too was of course awesome yeah i'm gonna
go with which we brought into this game
actually is it the actual school to lose
it expanded upon its it's the actual
school is warehouse in this cuz i saw in
the trailer yes and it looks a little
different uh it's a little bit bigger
yeah but it's the same layout yeah
that's great man yeah I'm really really
really excited for you can just tell
that you know that our Katie gameplay is
back and it's speaking of warehouse yeah
there we go so I'm seeing a lot of
things going on right now the one that I
played with you right is this warehouse
yes yes so we recently played a little
bit of THPS HD okay
for the first random turn of irony i'm
not a huge gamer but i work with these
guys and they're always talking about
games and Tim when he when we found out
he was going to talk to you was like you
need to play as many tony hawk games to
possibly ok otherwise you're gonna sound
like an idiot and i told him i'm gonna
sound like an idiot no matter what
that's just gonna happen but yeah
stepping in and playing this I mean I
it's a blast yeah I can understand but
he made me play warehouse for the first
time and I'm like it just looks so
dangerous in a good way I never really
thought of it that way while you're
doing smashing through glass you're
trying to change combos tree all the
same thing well I really like the
recovery time in my video game character
more than the human real life character
yeah because when i get hurt and you
know there's blood coming on my head and
whatever it's usually a few weeks at
least breaking on my skateboard and this
one you just got it could happen that's
always been a big big plus so how cool
is it seeing your kid in these games now
uh it's it's super exciting I mean he
you know he's successful in his own
right he he's kind of has his own path
and and he's already an established
professional so I thought he might
hesitate to want to do something like
this and the request came from the fans
they only come from me first yeah um so
when I asked him I thought that maybe he
would be you know a little wary of it
and he was he was into it so happy
that's awesome so what what's new about
this then we know it's going to be based
on the classic games but what are the
new elements we can look forward to uh
well well the online place is huge the
idea you can create levels and and those
will live in online community and people
can come in and play from all over the
world that's that's a huge bonus for us
other than that you know same controls
that you're used to there's a few extras
you can shoot projectiles you can buy
things on fire and things like that but
but I think it's gonna it's gonna bring
the same game playing the same feel to
the fans of the original series that's
great so in terms of what are your
favorite what do you think makes a Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater game um that's wow
that's that's uh that's that's a lot of
question what makes it uh the creativity
the idea that you can you can make your
own style you can you play in your own
style but still do the challenges that
it's that it is constantly challenging
that it's
you can keep coming back to the same
levels and trying all new all new Pat
all new combos and all new transfers and
things like that and the soundtrack
awesome I'll do you know what are the
announced skaters they're gonna be in
this game so far I do yes what are the
well brought up is you're wearing that
with us what's that we brought back
Andrew Reynolds awesome um we have Riley
Hawk of course we have dividend solace
with Nyjah Huston Aaron homoki jaws
who's considered doing the biggest kind
of drops these days Lizzie are manto who
I think is the best transition female
skater around and Leticia Bufoni who's
also accomplished street skater great
that's awesome so what it when you play
do you usually play as yourself or do
you play as someone else uh well I'm I'm
very used to my my special tricks yes so
I usually play as my care i'm not gonna
say i play with myself but i play out of
my character and uh and because
inevitably people want to challenge me
and so i gotta pick my character uh-huh
and and no all my special moves yeah
definitely that's awesome and so playing
this game does it feel right to you have
you played this new one yet oh
absolutely yeah does it feel rest
morning in fact I just I just put
together a combo at the barracks this
morning and posted online so you can see
you can see how I play if you look at my
Instagram and probably people who are
very avid fans in the series i'm gonna
say he sucks i'm better than him uh-huh
you like probably right OH just like
you're good at this game I'm good I'm
not exceptional yeah have you seen like
high-level play where people are just
yes Ainley good yes that's it's
impressive yeah really a million point
combos like that's yeah it's amazing to
me so we stick it with the theme here
where levels are based on the different
cities and stuff like do you think we
can expect to see some plastic locales
yeah you'll see there's there's a couple
of new levels but a couple of the old
favorites like this one right here yeah
man this makes me so excited to look at
I'm gonna throw this out there have you
tried yoga that's a pass now that I
affair or it if you know what it's more
um it's it's being active and constantly
skating that's kept me in shape now that
you're in ridiculously good shake maybe
if I it stops
then I'll take it up but not this poor
recommend my wife likes it for me okay
it's al it's a very link I mean you're
very tall and a little in the shorter
side we're sorry on but it's a very
lengthening thing very restorative and
according to you safer it's it's it is
I've had only one accident and yoga ok
but it was mostly me just accidentally
looking at someone else that I shouldn't
have been looking at while my wife was
doing yoga next oh there you go oh
that's right that's why the most
dangerous thing on the planet yeah
that's be far more dangerous this young
for me well the spirit of like looking
back at the the older games what are
some of your favorite memories that tony
hawk's pro skater has caused for you
like whether it's III or like playing
with people or whatever um well it I
mean it opens so many doors for me just
in terms of a career yeah and other
opportunities not just skating but but
being able to do other other passions I
think one of the coolest things uh I was
at a I was I don't know I think that an
awards show I can't remember Teen Choice
Awards I'm like that and I went I went
in the green room and mike tyson was
sitting on a couch alone and all these
people are doing all the other things
and so i sat down next to mike tyson i
was like hey what's up Mike I'm Tony
he's like Tony Hawk Tonio use it the
game thingy sir freaking out his fingers
like that's very awesome that is awesome
yeah that was one of my favorite like
wow moments yeah that's awesome oh no I
met Mike Tyson once guarantee doesn't
remember who I am yeah mostly cuz as he
was walking by me at comic-con I was
like Iron Mike and he was like yes that
is my name yeah he was super cool um
yeah I mean it's got to be crazy because
you've been in the public eye for so
long and this game has helped to do that
is is there ever an end in sight for you
do you ever think I'm gonna retire i'm
done i'm good i don't need to come to
these shows anymore hanging up the deck
oh I'm having too much fun I can't I
know it's not it's not an obligation I
really I'm passionate about I love the
game I still love skating as much as
ever so if I feel like I'm just going
through the motions and especially if I
feel like I'm just forcing it then I'm
not gonna do it I mean I couldn't I
couldn't do it for the sake of just
being a job yeah not for me how do you
feel about the state of skateboarding
right now are you happy where it's at
like do you feel that like
after Tony Hawk's Pro Skater after all
these things it was elevated at such a
high level do you think it's kind of
kept going from there I think so yeah I
think that the skating has gotten what's
bigger than ever it's definitely a
mainstay in terms of of pop culture for
what kids choose to do as an activity
you know it's more popular than Little
League these days so oh wow you know the
fact that we're bigger than the American
pastime that says something definitely
and I see a huge global growth in terms
of other countries I mean there's
there's a skate scene in Ethiopia
there's one in Cambodia there's one in
Afghanistan um and and other first of
all countries as well so I think
skateboarding's needed place for sure
that's awesome how what is your reaction
to the people's reaction to this game
announcement haha it's like that
question down how was your reaction to
other peoples to you it's been very
exciting um I love sharing it you know I
in fact I kind of go rogue with what I
share about the game haha good much to
act much appreciated yeah but yeah it's
really exciting and I can see fans of
the original series are really embracing
it yeah yeah that's definitely and
people think like why don't you do the
skate control scheme well because this
is th PS yeah exactly man yeah did you
would you have any thoughts on the
escape franchise um I thought it was
cool we you know we finally had some
competition and yet that it made
skateboarding in genre not just THPS but
it actually made skateboarding a genre
of video games it definitely split the
market yeah and maybe that's the reason
why we've been on hiatus for a while for
both of us yeah but I'm so stoked to
bring it back where it started yeah
definitely man I am so excited to play
this game do we have any idea of when
it's coming out what systems it's gonna
come out on any of that stuff well new
gen consoles first and I know when it's
coming out but they don't let me say
what is coming gosh you could just mouth
it to me this layer this one's the I
hesitated say older consoles but yeah
the previous three shortly after that
yeah that's really that big enough no
it's perfect it's it's perfectly bag
thing okay good for that all right yeah
um sorry Kevin just said something my
ear about to ask a question I didn't
actually Kevin say that
again please we'll all hold for you what
his favorite trick is what's your
favorite trick in the game um how many
let me ask you this is there a question
no one's ever asked you before I have a
better are I can't I can't just dig down
and you probably get this question a lot
which is my favorite dumb question to
ask someone do you have you played more
of the game than you think you've skated
in real life no no not nearly right not
at all no that was not I I always i
watch people ask professional athletes
at all the time like oh when you put you
play yourself and you know in madden or
whatever and they're always like you
know yeah i play myself but not nearly
as much as I actually lame really
waiting yeah yeah absolutely um but oh
yes for the favorite trick is I went
well one of my favorite tricks through
the years is has been ollie a nollie 540
like an ollie McTwist without grabbing
uh-huh because I feel like that that
changed the landscape of how you can
control the skateboard on your feet
without actually holding on to it yeah
man that's quite so how many tricks can
you credit to your name estimate I don't
I don't know you just don't even know no
I don't know man that's crazy it's it's
weird because now new tricks are just
combinations of old trick so it's hard
to claim ownership over any topic and I
hesitate to claim ownership over tricks
anyway because it's just like it it's
always been a collective effort yeah to
fall added you wanna shoot up yeah
create something yeah that's I got to
name my fair share of tricks that's
pretty cool good so did you come up with
the McTwist know who came up with a big
twist cuz that Mike McGill he deserves a
high five for sure Mike McGill deserves
a high five yeah I'm gonna ask the
obvious question I'm sure everyone at
home is asking what is the McTwist it's
a one and a half spin with sort of a
half somersault grabbing mute every one
of the comments was just like no [ __ ]
Nick I'm just doing that for you guys I
knew exactly what it was and I want a
mcdouble is also let me double i I'm a
big fat a couple of those yes in my life
Tim what's your favorite trick I feel
like we thought we've been at hammering
questions at tony for last 25 minutes I
was always a big fan of a twist yeah
twist is like kind of well I can't do it
but my favorite trick have you been on a
skateboard but I have been on skateboard
many times I'm very bad at it let's
break this down okay
yes um scale of one to ten compared to
Tony Hawk yeah are you good at anything
no probably not anything no yeah pretty
good you're on camera hosting is no all
right I'm all right boy but no one's
naming like if you're flipping a mic
around no one's gonna name that after
yeah I was appalled by the skateboard
where I didn't do it right where my foot
would be in the wrong place which I hear
is called [ __ ] oh that means you push
with the other push with my right foot
then I put it in front right cost a lot
of problems back in the day for me yeah
that that that is fodder for being made
fun quite a bit exactly what I
definitely I definitely did but so going
back to the game for a second I brought
it up earlier the soundtracks they've
always been such a key thing to me and
like a big part of the experience do you
have anything yet like chosen for the
soundtracks which we have some songs
chosen for sure how does that process
work of like choosing who gets to be in
the game you get to sit with a Spotify
playlist just be like no well I know my
I'm so steeped in skating history that I
really enjoy that what the soundtrack to
my growing up in skate parks was and
that was early punk rock yep saying I
still feel like oh so much about to draw
from so I've definitely put my share of
suggestions in and it's all about trying
to clear the rights to the music and
that's become way harder than ever
because no one's making money from
selling music anymore so it's like
licenses but but there have been a few
that I put in there there been a few
that have been that sort of fallen on us
and there's been a couple like people
bands on Twitter have begged me yes you
know and i will go listening and a
couple of them are actually ride along
lines of what we're looking for so
awesome man that's nothing with this new
age of the internet and Twitter and all
that stuff so it sounds like you're
pretty active on Instagram I try to be
oh yeah definitely on social media but
for in terms of the soundtrack I'm
active as well yeah that's great though
that's good but how has the being able
to talk to the fans directly how is that
change kind of what you do and how you
do it um wow it's well it's definitely
giving me the thicker skin yeah because
there's no offer anymore right now they
can tell you exactly what they think at
any other or just hurl insults at you do
so yeah be nice to Tony Hawk yeah I'm
just numb to the whole year old comment
that that doesn't affect me anymore I
get that all the time yeah least you
have all your hair see
you start getting this that's when they
really started throwing up hang out with
a guy it's putting a feedback is really
crucial you know yeah and it's funny
because I there's some things that you
think you're all maybe I should hold out
on that or hold back on it but at the
same time it's like I do want to share
it good or bad yep you know I would look
I welcome the feedback and and I'm not
going to go like backtracking and
deleting and things like that it's like
it's out there for you to see and I put
it out there so I stand by it that's
awesome so in terms of the mechanics
getting a little more into the
nitty-gritty of the game is the Reaver
going to be in this because this was
written three awesome great is the spine
transfer that was introduced in for
that's still difficult EVD all right I
want it if you could personally tell
somebody but Tim Gettys wants the spine
transfer I would appreciate a little bit
i'm in your camp yeah but they pony hair
is a buffer because he was gonna get
star getting closer and closer both of
you I haven't you ever steal your phone
to go for your email and figure out what
is and is not in the game but mine
Chancellor is definitely a topic of
debate Cole Cole Cole that's awesome is
there any feature that like you want to
see that isn't necessarily in it yet but
that you want to see comment like maybe
the caveman or something like that oh no
i'm i'm happy with with how it's come
along great um i think that time will
tell and and the fans will tell ya what
we should add or take out huh so a big
part Tony Hawk's Pro Skater has been the
secret characters you know we add
spider-man Wolverine Darth Maul
obviously the classics officer dick and
the Tony Hawk's Pro Skater exclusive
characters are we gonna see something
like that maybe yes that is exciting I
love that I'm very excited I can't tell
you of course they wouldn't be secrets
yeah wow I like that though what about
officer dick Toki tell me about officer
dick hahaha i cants and when to come out
hahaha sometimes like to throw that back
out to see if that's changed at all you
have not got you cannot tell us the
release date still right I can't that
hasn't changed in the last 15 minutes no
not i'll check my [ __ ] you know can't
say anything about that okay you've been
smiling over there which is really nice
so she's like no but I can tell that in
the back of your mind you're like get
him off stage right now get into the
next appointment where there's with a
reputable media outlets yes exactly so
so Tony besides Tony how
Pro skaters or any other games that
you're into playing uh well these days I
have kids and so many responsibilities
it's really hard to find time just play
at my leisure it's more just you know
phone games yep but uh my daughter plays
destiny she's 60 dusty okay and oh wow
she'sshe's and she plays destiny yeah
Wow not destiny infinity sorry oh I was
like wow seems like a genius know that
because they're able you know why cuz
they're right next to each other oh
why's that and all the other kids play
destiny III I told me she probably will
eventually dabble in destiny but for
right now in my she's not really just
she kind of watches like really that's
what they're doing yeah what's that I
don't get the game either I don't know
so right over there is huge into it but
I don't understand destiny that long
yeah so like if something gets tricky in
in infinity yeah yes um I have to finish
it before open there if you came to my
house at any given point I'd be playing
as brave yeah you know it's all
challenge yeah and we have a good friend
of ours great friend of ours mr. Hunter
Pence who plays for San Francisco Giants
he's he claims that playing video games
like fighters or games that require a
lot of skill help him on the field have
you noticed that at all ever know okay
so you're saying it might be if I it
gives me a false sense of recovery
really then I can just slam hit my head
and get right back up cuz my hope was
that if I play enough of this new one I
will eventually be able to at least jog
at a light pace without Donna I'll work
for you okay I'm sure ok I get the heart
up a little bit yeah yeah I'm keep going
okay we just have a few more minutes
left okay Tim do you have any last
questions let's see let's see let's see
if you're never gonna see him again
let's go more into the skateboarding
aspect of it then you talk a lot about
the like falling and like blood and
stuff is that a common thing and how do
you get over that the fear of getting
hurt um well there's always the fear of
getting hurt you know it's it's more
your approach to skating if you approach
it with confidence and you know you're
capable of doing whatever it is you set
out to do you're more likely to do it
and don't get hurt if you go with an
approach of oh not sure how this is
gonna happen or what's gonna happen here
you're gonna get hurt yeah yeah um but
it it's definitely part of skating you
know learning falling and learning and
and that separates a lot of time
separates the people who take it
seriously or not after your first injury
that's sort of the deciding factor like
are you going to continue with this do
you love it that much that you'll push
through this injury I've pushed through
probably more injuries than I should
have yeah still here to talk about it so
it's a blouse yeah that's good man it's
really great my god i want to see the
footage one more time Kevin can we pull
the footage up one more time Kevin Kevin
can you hear me because there was a
couple elements in here that I that
stood out to me not this this is pretty
clear we go here we go yeah okay Michael
so the wall rides back oh yeah laura is
there um I want to just break this down
real quick we only have a few more
minutes laughs so spoiler alert i'm
going to assume there's a secret tape
there was a up in that the breakable
glass over the halfpipe oh yeah and let
us escape combo and yep the time
challenges yeah all the other classic
modes so I like that this looks kind of
like a mix between hangar and warehouse
together yes yes and then here's a
school school yeah has there always been
a power grid above a school like that
that's day at that that right does there
has been but it didn't actually
Electrify your board there you go okay
so that's what's happened so what's
going on with the electricity right now
well it'll let you it let you access
different Mo's different tricks and
better better scores cool and I like I'm
big fan of the fire but what would I
want to leave things on fire as I skate
by them real life so does the fire like
hurt you at all now when it wouldn't
just made the big one no just you know
you just blazed a trail cool see what I
did there yeah like that like that a lot
that's here we go again sorry I'm
telling Kevin in my ear Kevin went from
screaming loud in my ear to a little
mouse quiet which is really uncommon for
him whoa there it is Jesus keV you guys
can't hear that but that sounded like
chaos yeah man I'm really excited for
this like again the Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater games have a very special place
in my heart and I seen this brings me
back I guys wanna play right now I want
in my head I have the muscle memory of
like the combo so you know especially in
warehouse of like jumping down into the
alley grinding on the rail doing the
whole thing yeah I have I have kind of a
default
trict set that I as soon as I get the
new build I'm on that and it's like all
right this feels this feels like you
used to well x games are you getting so
sorry but we are out of time so any
thanks so much for joining us yeah
thanks for that pleasure to meet you all
right you too thank you